L Le sénateur Pierre Hugues
BoBoisvenu revient à l la charg,
enen déposant pour une troisième
fofois un projet de loi visant e
momodification au code criminel,
momodification qui aiderait
leles jurés traumatisés à o obtr
dudu soutien psychologique
auau terme d'un procès.s.
O On reçoit Pierre-Hugues
BoBoisvenu. Dans quelle mesure
vovotre projet de loi aiderait s
jujurés qui ont besoin de souti?
- - Il faut comprendre que
l'ararticle 640 neuf du code
crcriminel ne permet pas un meme
dudu jury de dire quelque
ininformation qu'il a entendue u
vuvu lors des délibérations. Par
coconséquent Canada contrairemet
auaux Américains, les
dédélibérations d'un jury au
CaCanada sont tout à f fait
coconfidentielles et donner de
l'l'information obtenue lors de
seses délibérations, c'est un ae
crcriminel en vertu de cet
ararticle. Si ma mémoire est
vevertu de cet article. Si ma
mémémoire est bonne, en 2017,1
cocomité des ressources humaines
dede la chambre des communes
a a fait une étude sur la malade
mementale et les traumatismes qe
leles gens peuvent vivre et les
gegens qui participent à d des
jujurys, c'est devenu une espèce
d'd'évidence que ces gens-là, ,e
pepense à q quelqu'un qui étaitc
nonous, elle assistait comme jué
auau procès s Bernardo, et sorte
trtraumatisée de ce procès,s, en
plplus d'avoir collaboré pour
cocondamner cet individu. Donc s
gegens-là s sortent d'un procèst
lala justice pas les abandonnait
alalors qu'ils sont une piècece
mamaîtrtresse de notre systèmeme
jujustice. Aussi ce sont des
cicitoyens qu'on appelle à
enentendre procès s pour prendre
dédécision, les jurés sont au
cocoeur de la décision et ces
gegens-là s souvent n'ont pas la
foformation, c'est Monsieur,
MaMadame tout le monde, ils vont
sosortir d'une expérience qui
sosouvent va durer des semaines,
sosouvent ils sortent traumatisr
etet ils n'ont pas le droit et
chchercher de l'aide psychologie
ouou psychiatrique, peu importea
nanature, et de dévoiler aux
prprofessionnels ce qu'ils ont
enentendu lors des délibérations
alalors je pense que là-d-dessue
PaParlement a un devoir à f fai.
- - Il y a le secret des
dédélibérations mais qu'est-ce i
vovous porte à p penser que le
trtraumatisme de jure vient des
dédélibérations alors que ce sot
leles effets d'une cause qui sot
trtraumatisants. Dans Bernardo,
leles vidéos ont été diffusées n
plpleine cour, dans
auaussi, alors en quoi le secret
dedes délibérations
trtraumatiser les jurés?
- - Je discutais  avec quelqu'un
ququi me disait que souvent les
jujurés reçoivent de la pression
dede leur entreprise pour quittr
l'l'entreprise pendant des
sesemaines, souvent ils vont
peperdre leur emploi, s'ajoute u
ststress, le fait d'êtrtre isolé
pependant des semaines et d'être
chchallengé par rapport à n note
peperception de la culpabilité
dudu candidat. Et de se dire si
j'j'en parle à q quelqu'un je
cocommets un acte criminel. Alos
c'c'est un ensemble de faits.
SoSouvent des gens qui n'ont pas
lala formation pour traverser cs
ététapes sans séquelles. Une fos
quque c'est traversé on les laie
totomber. Alors on va dire à c s
gegens-là q qu'ils peuvent consr
unun professionnel, qui est lié
papar le secret professionnel dc
onon est certain que cette
ininformation n'ira pas plus lon
quque le bureau du professionnel
etet ça permet à d des gens de e
papas vivre pendant des années e
trtraumatisme. La sénatrice qui
apappuie ce projet de loi avec
momoi, qui en est la comarraine,
elelle a subi un tel événement l
y y a 29 ans et elle nous parlat
cece matin encore de son
exexpérience, ça lui a pris des
anannées à s se sortir de ce dr.
EtEt c'est pour cela qu'elle est
unune ardente défenseur de
susupporter les jurés lorsqu'ils
vivivent ses expériences.
- - Quand on a saisi comme juréu
CaCanada, on peut recevoir de
l'l'aide psychologique mais c'et
chchaque province qui gèrere son
prprogramme séparément. Il y a
auaussi un manque d'uniformité.e
seserait intéressant que ça rele
d'd'une loi au pays.
- - J'en ai discuté avec le
miministre de la justice, David
LaLametti, avant la dernièrere
élélection, d'une part
d'd'uniformiser les services mas
auaussi de les financer. C'est
bebeau de zéro juré : Bathurst
DeDelay : Silva dans les servics
pupublics il va attendre un an u
dedeux alors que Silva au privé,
ilil y aura des déboursés. Alors
onon essaie de voir comment
popourrait financer ses services
popour s'assurer qu'un jury qui
dedemande de l'aide, qui n'est s
dedes mois à a attendre et qu'on
pupuisse financer son service au
prpriv